how does summer wear two hats as a
director and as an actor how did you
compartmentalize yourself as actor
versus director or just well if you've
seen the film you'll realize it's not a
very powerful performance it was they
were kind of connected from the start to
write the two positions yeah she had to
position I mean grant yam you know I if
I would have had a budget and could have
been it picked somebody to play the part
definitely I would have just focus on
directing but I thought that I would
have worked well or that I could work
well with Brandon Marshall ration and
any roseanne ski I thought we had a nice
country so it was sort of when we didn't
have any other choice yeah we had no one
I didn't no one else I know we didn't
really pursue it that's what should
audition anybody but oh yeah I don't I
don't know we just we just handled it we
just we did what we needed to do um yeah
quickly you would even come in and and
did some blocking and we check out the
shot compose the shot do some more
blocking and you would hop out I think
she wardrobe was good yeah no rip it and
yeah just bouncing her and um do I
needed to do or yeah or not I mean I
don't know it was it was just it was it
was very weird it was there was
definitely an experience Morna over
there any days that it you just needed
to take five and just like be with
yourself in a dark room yeah there was
there is definitely some days that i was
on the verge of I'm losing it completely
um but the cool thing is that he you
know he went he on those days for him I
would be decent and on the dates where I
was you need to go to dark room he would
be decent sort he's like all right it's
good you know we'll work it out it will
work it out ya know it was a good
balance again very very lucky
have the someone like Joe I mean it
wouldn't have happened without Joe
teaming up on this project or without
the other actors I mean they had no true
but we were very lucky because everyone
knew that a lot was at stake and we had
no time and that we were trying to pull
something well then that that camera we
grew a lot after the first couple days
of days of shooting we'd hook up a
camera to the TV and we showed actors
the footage that we were getting and
after that point everybody was like okay
some here like this is looking good yeah
the first the first day if you will show
so it's not all but some I think they
didn't really know what to expect
because it's a crazy it's a goofy idea
and they kept movie they're thinking
like you know 20 people are gonna be
there and there's going to be craft
services and like here we come with like
a tripod and a DSLR and then just come
run it is older set it up and like piece
of foam cord we're looking up people
much confidence yeah help of at first
but it's amazing what you can do just
using tapes and simple stuff so simple
stuff yeah and I think they saw how
focused we were would then you know
couple beforehand but of course you can
talk about something all you want and
someone have an idea of it until you
actually get in there you're doing
something and then they realize okay
wait of it this is what it is and then
they see it they're like okay now i
understand it looks like a movie what we
have um so yeah it was cool to see
people's interest increasing more and
more and more with each day and
something else interesting what we would
pull off or something would happen we on
the visitors first day or two people are
moving kind of slow and then that kind
of picked up and by the end we were like
let's let's do one more scene today yeah
we couldn't isn't there scene we can do
inside tonight it was funny because we
we then started picking up incredible
steel it is crushing through scenes and
like Joe said at the very end we
finished and basically
everyone's like okay what's next when I
goes that's it we got it
you